the repercussions of a potentially
damaging trade war between the US and
China right now it remains a war of
words between the world's two largest
economies but yesterday stocks plunged
after the president threatened to
escalate the tariff battle and then
words by his Treasury Secretary added to
the fear the Dow finished down 572
points losing just over 2% of its value
Niki batiste is here with more Nicki
good morning good morning Friday capped
off a rollercoaster week for the markets
the ups and downs on Wall Street
reflected back and forth between the
United States and China as the two
countries continue to propose tariffs on
goods imported into each country this
sell-off started shortly after the start
of trading Friday morning as mounting
fears of a trade war with China weighed
on investors is this now a trade war mr.
secretary no it's not and our objective
is still not to be in a trade war with
them the Dow had already dropped more
than 300 points by 1:00 p.m. Eastern
when Treasury secretary Steve minuchin
appeared on CNBC on the one hand were
willing to continue negotiations on the
other hand the president is absolutely
prepared to defend our interests those
comments didn't seem to calm the markets
with the Dow dropping more than 600
points before ticking up slightly by
closing on Friday President Trump shook
off any concerns about short-term
fluctuations in a radio interview so we
may take a hit and you know what
ultimately we're going to be much
stronger for it but it's something we
had to do the president accuses China of
stealing US intellectual property and
other violations of global trade rules
last month in response the
administration announced tariffs on
imported Chinese aluminum and steel this
week China fired back threatening to put
tariffs on 50 billion dollars worth of
US agricultural products like pork and
soybeans now President Trump is said to
be considering 100 billion dollars of
additional tariffs in response nothing's
happened nothing's been executed White
House National Economic Council director
Larry Kudlow told reporters the u.s. is
open to negotiations
but said there should be no doubt who's
to blame blame China don't blame the
administration don't blame Japan don't
blame Europe blame China because they
have to put their best foot forward
and act like a world power the worry is
extending all the way to the Fed Federal
Reserve Chairman Jerome Powell says
businesses are expressing their concern
and that the prospect of a trade war
with China was discussed at the feds
March meeting Anthony Nicky batiste
thanks Nicky